[Musica]
quando ero piccola la maestra portava in
bambini in due file maschia destra né
femmina sinistra o viceversa
a un certo punto si vede che ho litigato
con un bambino gli ho tirato un calcio
nello stand quel bambino si è messo a
piangere la palestra ferma la fila
capisce secondo me gli altri meno
sputtanata chi aveva dato il calcio
all'altro bambino e ovviamente mi
punisce ma che cosa fa diceva a veronica
hai dato un calcio ma i calci sono da
maschi si vede che vuoi essere un
maschio e ne ha messa in mezzo alla fila
dai maschi divertiti
io so stata umiliata in un modo atroce e
non ho raccontato niente a casa al
giorno d'oggi questa cosa mi turba molto
la mia maestra è stata veicoli di
sterotipo stereotipi incoscienti che io
chiamo lei l'ha fatto a fin di bene
punirmi ma non mi è punita perché ho
dato un calcio all altro essere umano
lei mia punita perché secondo lei cosa
da maschi
a questa cosa mi ha fatto pensare che da
piccoli abbiamo due religioni
la maestra e i nostri genitori e loro
formano la nostra visione del mondo
attraverso la loro
noi non abbiamo modo di farci la nostra
sono loro che attraverso le loro azioni
i loro discorsi il loro modo di punirci
fanno sì che ci facciamo un'idea per
fortuna a casano dei genitori che mi
facevano giocare con arco e frecce sugli
alberi anche con le bambole quindi avuto
un'educazione molto più variata di non
quella stereotipata che ricevevo a
scuola questa cosa però mi ha fatto
riflettere a qom educhiamo le nostre
bambine secondo dei concetti di
gentilezza di pulizia di essere carine
di non essere aggressive e questi
concetti vengono perpetrati anche dalle
favole se ci pensate
le favole che avevo io la mia età io ho
40 anni erano che c'era questa
principessa bella bella bella in modo
assurdo a un certo punto arrivava un
principe la salvava e vivevano felici la
principessa non faceva niente
a volte dormiva anche fino agli anni 50
l'unica modo di sopravvivere per una
donna era il matrimonio o ti sposavi
parigi dello ti facevi suora ma non è
che c'erano altre opzioni
quindi venivamo educate come prodotti da
piazzare prodotti da piazzare al meglio
sul mercato questo cosa fai quando devi
per piazzare ben è un prodotto al fai
bello lo fai attrattivo per fare un buon
per trovare un buon partito e quindi
eravamo educate belle per essere super
belle gentili giovani sempre giovani e
possibilmente vergini così non c'erano
dubbi sulla paternità dei figli serigi
della era un peso per la tua famiglia e
comunque il concetto di single ripeto
non esisteva l'indipendenza non è
un'opzione
il marketing di massa che è nato grosso
modo gli stessi anni negli anni 50
quindi giocava su questi tre concetti
giovinezza bellezza fertilità e fare le
mamme
il marketing si basa tutt'oggi su questi
concetti che vanno attraverso la
frustrazione
ok soprattutto però c'è una sorta di
antagonismo fra le pubblicità che ci
vogliono tutte sexy ci fanno vedere sexy
e il fatto che noi comunque dobbiamo
essere morigerate serie 1 che trova
tanto va bene se tu hai molti partner
non va bene sei una poco seria provate a
dire una cena che avete avuto magari una
cinquantina di partner sessuali
consenzienti vi guarderanno un po male
ok io ci provo spesso è buffo ma questa
cosa mi fa riflettere aver avuto tanti
partner fa di me una cattiva persona una
cattiva professionista o farebbe di me
una cattiva madre
io non credo però il mondo ci vuole così
è una teoria che l'ho chiamata la paura
dall'infinito femminile e questa teoria
consiste nel fatto che biologicamente
fisiologicamente un uomo può avere poi
iacolare un certo numero di volte in una
giornata mentre una donna può aver
influito il rasmi in sé leva se trova
quindi averli da sola in compagnia
eccetera
e questo rende il mondo della sessualità
completamente dispari fra uomini e donne
questo fatto si secondo me che nella
storia noi siamo state molto contenute
per i nostri aspetti sessuali e si vede
ancora in tante religioni
quindi siamo ancora succubi del fatto di
avere i tre concetti cardine giovinezza
e soprattutto bellezza per il car
il marketing moderno anche se il mondo
nel frattempo è cambiato ma noi non ce
ne importa nulla perché siamo cresciute
con quei simboli
sappiamo che siamo molto di più di un
corpo ma vogliamo comunque il corpo
perfetto
ora io ve lo dico la prova costume non
esiste per noi lo sappiamo ma lavoriamo
tutto l'anno in palestra con le diete
per quei quindici giorni di vacanza
eppure l'anno a 365 giorni e non
lavoriamo il nostro corpo per essere
sane e in salute tutto l'anno no per la
prova costume è il concetto che non mi
torna
ora io da pro la figliola a 29 anni
era laureata politicamente corretta
avevo un contratto a tempo determinato
mi ero sposata aveva un loft tutto mio
che volevo un bambino ora un certo
appunto la vita e prepotente succedono
delle cose e non ho potuto avere il
bambino per una serie di motivi quindi
il mio il mio piano politicamente
corretto di caselle è crollato
credevo che la mia vita fosse finita
perché io avevo un piano preciso quel
però un altro spicci due anni dopo
lanciava una start up era single e
viveva in un furgone
perché il mio piano prevedeva che io non
dovevo spendere per totali in affitto
però dopo anni di caselle compre
politicamente corrette avevo cominciato
a progettare io le mie caselle e nelle
mie caselle andare a vivere un furgone
per due anni e alla scelta giusta da
fare senza pensare cosa avrebbero detto
gli altri e che succede quando tu
disegni le due caselle cominci a vivere
secondo quello che tu vuoi veramente
fare e non quello per cui sei stata
indottrinata a fare succedono cose
bellissime
io ci sono riuscita grazie ai tacchi e
vedete che c'entrano i tacchi tutto
questo centrando molto perché io nel mio
lavoro l'uso come uno strumento di
empowerment questa cosa qua
in pratica ho messo insieme una cosa
molto frivola come quella di un tacco
che tutti pensano che sia un vezzo con
le pari opportunità ed è uno strumento
fisiologico di empowerment ora non so se
ci sono donne in sala che usano i tacchi
e se io chiedessi come vi sentite
condendo stati fatti sapete rispondermi
come vi sentite potenti power c'è un
motivo ben preciso per cui una donna si
sente power quando mette un paio di
tacchi ma cominciamo da lontano gli
uomini hanno in media 11 manifestazioni
e rettili al giorno
le donne no perché abbiamo un organo
interno loro esterno onorano talmente
tanta confidenza che vi danno dei nomi
ci sono un sacco di aggettivi anche in
tante lingue non c'è le palle 6 cazzuto
ilha de cui skype boskov hoeness
eccetera e
male si dice anche alle donne tu sei una
donna con le palle
ora io onestamente non le vorrei e non
mi piacerebbe neanche che mi ci sono sei
stata una grande chuene affida così
neanche quindi noi non colleghiamo
questa cosa della potenza virile con la
carriera e il potere gli uomini in
eccessiva che succede però quando una
donna mette i tacchi
cambia la postura avete sapete che con i
tacchi ai più seno più glutei
ok ma perché ci dobbiamo raddrizzare
avere uno schiacciamento lombare questo
schiacciamento lombardi cosa fa porta il
sedere più indietro però così facendo il
nostro membro si sposta di circa 4 cm
all'indietro e questo crea una cosa
molto particolare a livello fisiologico
noi sentiamo che abbiamo un membro
perché le labbra si aprono leggermente e
questo sentire ci fa entrare la stessa
dinamica sesso potere carriera degli
uomini ma con un attributo fammi
femminile e un ager un accessorio
femminile perché quando le donne sono
arrivate in massa al lavoro si sono
mascolinizzato nell'aspetto col tailleur
pantalone nella nell'agire con la colla
aggressività perché l'uomo l'essere
umano domina il mondo perché la capacità
di adattarsi ora secoli di dominazione
maschile nel mondo del lavoro avevano
reso il mondo del lavoro dalle dinamiche
maschili la donna quando arrivata che ha
fatto
beh ha detto io mi adatto e ha confuso
mascolinità con così sono professionale
quindi non andate a dire a una
neolaureata di non andare a un colloquio
in tailleur pantalone perché lei sembra
così perché solo così sente di essere
professionale
ora il problema è che voi mi direte
adesso sì il cavolo però mi devo mettere
i tacchi per sentirmi [ __ ] per sentirmi
power
no è un espediente un esercizio se tu ti
senti male una mattina infinito i tacchi
ti senti una [ __ ] vai e conquisti il
mondo e lo puoi fare anche togliendoli
perché appunto un esercizio
ok nel 2017
non abbiamo più bisogno di sposarci per
sopravvivere siamo indipendenti siamo
nostre
ora il marketing però continuo
martellare sui soliti concetti deve
essere giovane e bella [ __ ] sei grassa
sei brutta sei vecchia chissenefrega si
sono grassa brutta e vecchia onestamente
possiamo riprenderci la nostra immagine
ok e non c'è nessun principe siamo noi
il principe
ora ci sono tantissime leader che adesso
cominciano a parlare è diventata quasi
una moda vinci un premio weil e fa il
discorso femminista e di moda ma non
possiamo lasciare le leader da sole
portare avanti questa causa l'idea è
questa l'idea questa dicono che le
rivoluzioni non si fanno sulle tastiere
ora io ci sono andata in piazza l'otto
marzo c'era pochissima gente per quello
che è veramente la causa femminista la
causa della donna la parola femminista
un po di sanders le rivoluzioni si
possono fare nelle tastiere l'idea è
questa la società avanza per la media
non per i picchi che possono essere le
speaker è bene che ci siano loro perché
ci dicono qualcosa sta cambiando
qualcosa si muove ci ascoltano ci
facciamo sentire ma noi siamo milioni e
tutti quanti abbiamo un telefonino tutti
quanti abbiamo un influenza nel nostro
entourage e tutti quanti possiamo andare
a dire a un brand che la pubblicità che
sta facendo e l'uso dell'immagine della
donna che stava facendo in quel momento
con quella campagna a noi non piace non
andare lì a trattarli male no io dico di
essere attive di diventare attiviste
digitali in modo costruttivo
quindi possiamo anche assumere donne
possiamo promuovere campagne virtuose
andare a protestare nelle campagne che
non ci piacciono e condividere storie
perché condivide una piccola storia di
un'amica che magari si è lanciata in
propria avuto questa idea cambiato vita
fra le centinaia di amici che abbiamo
magari
la persona vedendo quella condivisione
quella propria storia nostra può avere
quel click in testa che le fa pensare
cavolo ha ragione magari posso farlo
anch'io e può cominciare un nuovo
percorso da sola quindi la condivisione
le reti sono importanti non pensate di
essere piccole non pensate che non avete
il potere di boicottare un brand per
quello che parlo di media per quello che
parlo di piccole azioni e per quello che
parlo che siamo veramente milioni e un
click può fare la differenza può fare a
fare clic nella testa di un'altra io
sono un attivista digitale da 11 anni e
ricevo tantissime lettere quindi so che
funziona
non lasciateci soli però ognuno di noi
può fare una piccolissima cosa e ha
senso farlo e non è mai piccola ci vuole
costo coraggio soprattutto costanza
perché siamo tutti bravi l'otto marzo
tutti ma l'otto marzo una volta l'anno e
noi stiamo lottando per i nostri diritti
per abbattere gli stereotipi da troppi
secoli
quindi noi siamo milioni
noi siamo il mercato e il mercato
possiamo deciderlo noi quindi
raccontatevi condividete creati
scintille
eri e dichiaro il mondo a nostra
immagine e somiglianza perché noi noi
siamo milioni di cui grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]